instalan la ventilación y decoran el
baño estos trabajadores dan los últimos
toques a un centro para refugiados
ucranianos en praga el proyecto es una
creación de pavel skin un fotógrafo de
paisajes ruso que se mudó a república
checa en 2008
y
lo escribo como mi guerra puedo disparar
y podría ir a la guerra pero seré más
sutil aquí y así es como pelearé
mientras putin siga peleando yo pelearé
de esta manera
si el espacio era una tienda vietnamita
programada para ser demolida pero a
través de facebook skin logró recaudar
19 mil euros para las renovaciones y
recibió una donación de una ong el
centro alberga 16 refugiados y puede
acoger a decenas más dispone de dos
cocinas 10 duchas 10 baños sala de
juegos para niños y un salón para
adultos después de arduos viajes para
llegar a república checa los refugiados
están agradecidos por tener un lugar
seguro donde quedarse y
estamos muy agradecidos hicieron muy
buen alojamiento con buenas
instalaciones eso es lo que necesitamos
nos bombardearon mucho la última noche
que estuvimos en casa fue aterrador los
niños ni siquiera durmieron por la noche
cosquín que ha alojado a otros 15
refugiados con dos gatos y un perro en
su estudio ahora está ayudando a los
ucranianos a encontrar empleo en
república checa